what's up marvel fans we're here with
kevin feige this is a huge undertaking
of a film where did you start
uh we started at the ending of far from
home where we knew that we had put peter
parker in a very hard
circumstance where his identity was
revealed and from there we decide what
happens next and how do we make things
harder for him he's been to space he's
become
spider-man he's lost his mentor and now
his identity is revealed and all he
wants to do is graduate high school and
go to college and we started there and
the good old parker luck kicked him
you brought super villains in from
previous spider-man movies into this
what was that process like uh it was
very emotional it always starts with a
place of what do we think would be fun
what do we think would be cool i've been
making movies for 20 years now at marvel
and they started at this very theater as
a matter of fact with the premiere of
sam raimi's spider-man one
and we were sitting around a room and
saying if i saw willem dafoe who you
just talked to as green goblin again and
alfred molina who's not able to be here
tonight at stockhock i would lose my
mind just that just that starting point
um and uh and a lot of luck came
together that they were interested we
were able to bring them back oh that's
incredible i can't wait to see this
incredible film what are you most proud
of throughout this spider-man films well
i'm proud of the collaboration we've had
with with john watts on three movies
with tom holland on three of his own
movies plus the avengers movies the
entire relationship between sony and
marvel and disney is really
unprecedented in hollywood history and
it's all because everybody loves
spider-man and and that is amazing i
hope it shows in all the movies as well
we said everyone loves spider-man what
makes them so lovable and relatable
uh i think that was the genius of what
steve ditko and stan lee did all those
years ago was they made him us they made
him flawed and related and again here he
is in this giant anticipated movie that
may or may not have consequences for the
multiverse but peter parker just wants
to go to college peter parker just wants
to graduate high school that's it
uh and and
you you you want to root for that person
kevin thank you so much enjoy the movie
thank you so much have a good night
thank you
[Music]
you